the speedforce this time we're not going
to necessarily see Barry's experience in
deceive speedforce we'll see kind of the
effects that the speedforce has had on
Barry and he's been in there six months
real-time but the way I see it is the
Speed Force is kind of nonlinear what
time so Barry is experienced kind of his
entire life from start to end infinity
times over since he's been in there so
he's going to have kind of an awakening
when he comes out he's going to be I
think he's got some knowledge that he
probably doesn't even quite understand
yet he'll also be a little scrambled he
won't really be himself
the first time we see him everybody
flash is almost back Grant Gustin is
talking about Barry coming out of the
Speed Force with all kinds of new
knowledge and abilities so let's break
it down there were also a bunch of you
asking about the negative flash who has
all these crazy new powers in the comics
I'll explain that after I talk about
Flash's and for stuff because I'm not
expecting a whole bunch of that to
happen on the TV show this year negative
Speed Force is a slightly different
concept and the whole idea is that
they're trying not to go back to that
speedster well again so they'll probably
save negative Speed Force for the next
time the reverse flash gets a big story
but all the rebirth stuff that grant
gustin's been hyping up has served a
couple important functions one that they
start the new season with a new version
of Barry's that can just dump all the
baggage from the previous season so no
more moping Barry sad crying about
things that he can't change or trying to
change things in getting that damn it
Barry response from all his friends even
Candice Patton was joking that they
should rename the show damn it Barry
because so much of the show just turns
on all the mistakes that he's made the
last couple of seasons flashpoint damn
it Barry how dare you didn't we have
this lesson during season one so Grant
Gustin the producers are saying that all
that bullsh is gone you show up with a
new version of Barry that's lived what
seems like several lifetimes in the
spans of the last couple months since we
last saw him go into the Speed Force so
it's sort of like the Esther sketch way
to fix your character it's a really
clever way to because it makes sense the
Speed Force is a place that exists
beyond space-time so if somebody went in
and came out with a completely different
personality it would actually make sense
so he'll still be the flash he's still
the comic book flash
but the writers the actors don't have to
hang on to any of the stuff they feel
like didn't work out or didn't really go
the way they wanted to last season like
the big comment is that they waited too
long to do this avatar reveal things got
a little too dark a little too
depressing he just comes back now and
he's a completely different person boom
poof problem solved you probably heard
them referencing season one a lot like
we really like the way season 1 felt it
was exciting to be the flash to learn
about all these new abilities every
single week so number 2 berry comes out
of the Speed Force and he can do that
again because like Grant Gustin says in
this interview he doesn't fully
understand everything he has all this
new information and he just has to start
to sift through it that's actually
happening on Game of Thrones right now
he comes out of the Speed Force with
ultimate knowledge and abilities but
doesn't completely understand how to use
it or how to access it on command so you
get your upgraded more powerful version
of the flash in the future flash costume
big costume upgrade right off the bat
but week to week you also get to see him
discover new abilities like oh my god I
didn't know I could do that so there's a
lot of cool abilities from the comics
that they could choose to do on the TV
show most of them are destructive
abilities which I'm not expecting like
you know the finger-snap he can create
sonic booms when he snaps his finger the
reason why they probably don't do that
is because they'd have to replace all
those windows every time they wanted to
shoot a scene so that's probably why you
haven't seen that on-screen yet but the
whole idea is that the new powers that
you see each season have something to do
with him fighting the villain so if this
season's villain is the thinker then
they'll probably be more mental based
powers so what I'm expecting is is it'll
be a slightly upgraded version where he
can retain anything that he reads for 30
minutes so he can become an expert on
anything for up to 30 minutes so if the
thinker is so much smarter and
complicated than villains that he's
faced before he's going to have to learn
how to be a better detective which is
one of the reasons why they probably
chose to go with the elongated man
because in the comics he's a detective
too and what have we not seen on the
flash the last couple of seasons Barry
doing really good CSI work like most of
the CSI stuff last season was all Tom
Shelton's character so they said they're
going back to season 1 5 what did he do
to
during season one he did a lot of CSI
work so it sounds like he'll be using
new abilities to aid in detective work
but there are also a couple of other
abilities that are really easy for them
to do on screen one of the new ones that
they showed up during season 3 that
Barry never really figured out was how
to travel extra fast using the Speed
Force as a conduit so normally the flash
runs through three-dimensional space
like he just runs from point A to point
B as fast as he can but there's all
kinds of drag heat buildup and any
mental obstacles that he might have the
fastest way to run is actually to jump
into the Speed Force which exists beyond
space time and then just jump back out
whichever point you want to be at so
that's how you could go across the earth
in an instant he wouldn't run across the
earth he was sort of tunneled through
the Speed Force the way that we saw
avatar do in the first couple of
episodes and also another ability is a
way to passively borrow and give speed
to other speedsters so like he and Wally
are helping out on a problem and he
needs to help Wally be faster he can
just grant Wally a portion of his speed
or vice versa but when you're thinking
about new abilities for the flash to
have just remember that he's fighting
the thinker and he's not so much like a
big villain like zoom that he would just
try to outrace or punch in the face he's
a master mind character playing four
dimensional chess so Barry has to learn
how to play chess better using his Speed
Force abilities but obviously it's a
television show so it's not going to be
the two of them sitting at a table all
season so let me know in the comments
which other new powers do you want to
see him use during this season he's
already done most of the things we've
seen the flash do but he has to go full
neo like if you've read that original
sink or arc that Geoff Johns wrote it
reads very much like The Matrix movie in
that story the flash winds up beating
him inside digital space not in physical
space and normally that'd be a big
disadvantage for him but as of right now
I believe they're finishing filming
episodes for maybe beginning episode 5
we've already seen the elongated man on
set that's who this actor is there's
been no mention of sued in B's so I'm
expecting it'll just be him and it might
be before he meets her maybe she's dead
and it's some sort of tragic thing like
Kaitlin lost Ronnie during season 1 like
my girlfriend died and the part of
accelerator explosion so we'll see about
that but I think he's going to be what
you see is what you get with the
exception of the powers like wow you
have some crazy abilities you look kind
of like mr. fantastic so I'm expecting
all kinds of memes when he debuts on the
show I think it's going to be either
episode 3 or episode 4 it's not going to
be right away but as for negative flash
like moving into pure comic-book stuff
if you haven't been reading the flash
comic book reverse flash tried to trap
Barry in the negative speed force it
backfired he became infused with the
negative Speed Force and came out almost
with a completely different personality
completely different powers it's almost
like he's been poisoned and now he's
trying to learn how to use those new
abilities and figure everything out but
his speed force energy he calls it
unpredictable the negative Speed Force
when it leaves speed trails will just
blow stuff up is this really explosive
force so he takes down some criminals
and then turns around to see what's
happened in the wake of their run and he
winds up causing way more damage himself
than any of the criminals did like he
literally rips the street apart so it
makes you wonder if that's part of the
reason why the reverse flash was such an
because Barry suddenly gets a
lot madder it's almost like he's been on
steroids like the smallest thing will
set him off he's much quicker to anger
I'm mad so you see this face here and
you're like okay he looks exactly like
the reverse flash here maybe these are
some of the things that made the reverse
flash such an evil person so like I said
I'm not expecting the TV show to ever
address this stuff this season without
the presence of the reverse flash and
they haven't said exactly when he's
coming back right now odds are after the
mid-season finale and they'll just spend
most of the first half of the season
dealing with all the new Barry stuff
like oh my god everything's new Barry's
a little bit different he has new powers
there's a couple new characters there's
a new villain called the thinker then
the second half of the season then
they'll start to bring back some of the
really big stuff but we do know that
Gorilla Grodd for instance is going to
guest star a lot on legends of tomorrow
he'll be one of the bigger villains of
that season so that'll be pretty cool so
lots of Flash stuff happening all over
the air overs so leave all your requests
for flash videos in the comments below
I'll say congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Coby shank you in a
flash
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round in
this video all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
the video and while you wait for
everything you can click here to rewatch
that new Justice League trailer and you
can click here for brand new Game of
Thrones thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight